good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight we're about to bring you what
has become unfortunately a nightly
update on the Descent of our nation into
chaos and craziness a lot of craziness
for more than two weeks this is really
all we've covered there's that much
going on right now we can't cover it all
in an hour almost all of it as you know
all the news is horrifying vandals are
defacing our country they're destroying
our cities or institutions our civil
society they have no right to do any of
that they don't own this country they
did not build it the rest of us should
not allow them to wreck it but we are
allowing them and it's infuriating to
watch we've definitely been infuriated
genuinely if you've watched this show
you probably notice that it's not we
want to apologize for that
here's why the last thing America needs
right now is more anger yet another
red-faced screamer shouting about this
or that and it's extend that spinasse
we're sorry we genuinely want to help
fix this disaster so adding to the sum
total of rage does not help going
forward we can see we're gonna continue
to be as honest as we can that's our
duty above all we try to be honest on
this show sincerely but we're also going
to work to be calm and amused because
honestly what's the option right now
keep your sense of humor that's what
they tell you when things get really
dark and it's good advice humor brings
perspective all of us could use some
perspective right now so with that in
mind we want to begin tonight with a
geography quiz here it is how many
countries are there on earth last week
there were a total of 195 but if you
guessed that you're wrong because
tonight there 196 ladies and gentlemen
say hello to the latest addition to the
global family of nations the capitol
hill autonomous zone formerly known as
downtown Seattle
well you can point in wow this is our
street it's our station well that looks
pretty appealing but before you jump on
Expedia to book a trip with the family
to the Capitol Hill autonomous zone now
known by the way as Chas the country's
tourism and Economic Development
Department is calling it that you should
know that there are no beaches in Chas
this is a tiny nation it's smaller than
Liechtenstein the entire country extends
only six city blocks it was built on
land that was formerly owned in part by
the Seattle Police Department but the
founders of Chas wanted that land so
they planted a flag and they stole it
just like the conquistadors the first
thing they did after they declared
nationhood and this was a bit of a
surprise given that these modern
conquistadors claim to be progressive
ideologues but the first thing he did
was establish rigid national borders
they built a wall around the place just
like Donald Trump once said he would do
their wall is made from wooden
barricades a sign at the entrance to the
country warns you are now leaving the
USA and then there are armed bart border
guards not technically ice agents but
close enough who questioned everyone
seeking entry countries have borders and
the founders of chaz understood that
they don't want the place flooded with
illegals and by illegals we mean the
citizens of Seattle we have been hearing
commute from community members that they
have been subjected barricades set up by
the protesters with some armed
individuals running them as checkpoints
and
what's pretty smart you can't let just
anyone into your country an uncontrolled
flood of immigrants would tank the
economy and the people of chas know that
they're not libertarians they don't work
for the Chamber of Commerce they're not
giving you some speech about how
immigration makes you richer they're
realists they want to make this work for
the sake of their people and they don't
have much to work with what exactly is
the economy of chas
it's tough with limited natural
resources and a population with
virtually no skills of any kind
apart from spray-painting the f-word on
public buildings they lead the world in
that the people of Chas don't have a lot
of options for economic development so
they've gone with extortion through
violence again just like the
conquistadors
it's a time-tested formula and it's
lucrative we have heard anecdotally
reports of citizens and businesses being
asked to pay a fee to operate within
this area this is the crime of extortion
well like the nation it broke fun its
mother nation the United States the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone is what
political philosophers call a
proposition nation it's a country based
on an idea rather than particular people
the founding idea in Chas it's Magna
Carta its constitution its raison d'etre
these the cops are bad very very bad the
police are bad and should be a Papa
polished so not surprisingly Chas has
banned police from its territory the
surrounding sidled city of seattle seems
okay with that decision I mean does the
government of Italy dictate local
policies within the Vatican City no of
course not it's autonomous same thing
here what's amazing though is that the
leaders of Chas would like to dictate
policies in the City of Seattle and so
they're demanding that sale get rid of
its police force and close all jails and
prisons at this point Chas has not yet
been admitted to the UN presumably
there's an email headed there now
but as the Seattle Police Chief Carmen
best explained the country already has
recognition from the seattle city
government the decision to born at the
precinct our precinct our home
the first precinct I worked in
with something I have been holding off
you should know leaving the precinct was
not my decision you fought for days to
protect it I asked you to stand on that
line
day in and day out to be pelted with
projectiles to be screamed at threatened
and in some cases hurt then to have a
change of course nearly two weeks in it
seems like an insult to you in our
community ultimately the city had other
plans for the building and relented to
severe public pressure pretty powerful
police chief pretty pretty formidable
law enforcement leader I'm sure the
people of Seattle feel well protected so
Chaz is a nation without leaders it's a
flat system it's anarchy how long can
that continue probably not very long
anarchy isn't built to last in the end
the strong always dominate the weekend
in fact it's already happening it took
barely a day for the nation of Chaz to
get its first war load and it was quite
a promotion for him just a week ago Raz
Simone was an up-and-coming rapper he
was also a super host for air B&B now
he's a monarch in videos taken with in
Chaz Simone had seen patrolling the area
with his allies they have guns they're
declaring we're the police now in one
clip the Monarchs men assault a citizen
of Chaz for spray-painting graffiti
inside the zone just like the Mafia Chaz
doesn't put up with nonsense like that
in their own neighborhood so that's
what's happening in Seattle sight not a
big deal a brand new nation within our
own borders yes the last time that
happened it did kick off a civil war
that killed hundreds of thousands of
Americans in lasted three years but it's
not a huge deal and that may be why
Democrats in Congress seem completely
unaware that it's happening Nancy posea
said nothing about it and neither has
Adam Schiff and you'd think they kind of
have their finger on the pulse of the
nation the mayor of Seattle knows about
it obviously it's happening downtown but
doesn't seem bothered in the slightest
in fact in the last few days the mayor
of Seattle Jenny Durkin has tweeted in
honor of a deceased gay icon in the city
she's bragged about building new housing
for the homeless until tonight she
didn't even acknowledge the exist
of chess again a nation built in her
downtown the president noticed the last
time he tweeted this take back your city
now if you don't do it I will this is
not a game these ugly anarchists must be
stopped immediately move fast mayor of
Seattle replied this way simply make us
all safe
go back to your bunker a clever social
media wordsmith there are questions
though unresolved for example what will
happen to the American citizens who may
have been shopping downtown in Seattle
and are now stuck behind the border of
chazz can we repatriate them are they
now prisoners of war these are questions
of international diplomacy at this stage
but the mayor has not addressed them she
did say tonight that jazz is really like
a block party and she said she might
grant some of their demands presumably a
bilateral treaty is imminent we'll be
bringing you that news when it happens
the media haven't paid a lot of
attention to Chas either they're excited
by anything that's new but not into this
new country it's kind of weird because
just a month ago they were very against
demonstrators the anti lockdown
demonstrators in Michigan for example
were dangerous zealots really just an
ugly a dangerous scene at the State
Capitol in Michigan black people's right
to protest is secondary to white
people's right to be an armed protest
with long guns bunch of guys camo'd up a
bunch of guys with long guns he's
potentially dangerous protests against
they at home orders tiny minority with
guns marched into the state capitol in
Michigan today to lobby in their raucous
way when it's white people with guns and
they're out and they're angry and their
faces with cops
didn't see any of that everybody's civil
wrongs Oh we set the top this show we're
gonna try to stay amused not have family
play those clips and every night it's
just aw it makes you red in the face how
can people that stupid have TV shows and
that dishonest but tonight let's
acknowledge it is amusing because here's
the standard if you protest lockdowns in
Michigan with guns but don't commit any
violence at all
it's a threat to the nation but if you
commit beatings and loot and burn down
buildings you are quote mostly peaceful
if you create an armed independent
nation in downtown Seattle it's amazing
good call the New York Times is on your
side and in fact just today the New York
Times published a piece that described
the nation of chaz as quote a homeland
for racial justice
so we've homeland's now in the middle of
our country the nation of chaz is we're
getting quoting the New York Times here
quote in experiment in life without the
police part street festival part commune
it has free food and that's what it
takes to make everything right just get
rid of the police how do we how many of
the people writing this stuff would go
spend a week in Chas with their families
or in Chad for that matter zero what
that didn't slow ABC down it described
Chas as quote festive basically like
Free Tibet except in this case the media
actually supported because China's on
board too we got to explore this
question more the press the Democratic
Party have repeatedly condemned
protesters who carry weapons simply to
make a point with no intention of using
them and don't use them and of course
last winter we had an entire impeachment
charade based on the idea that nobody is
above the law no one is above the law
nobody no one is above the law
no one is above the law no one's above
the law no one that no person is above
the law nobody should be above the law
no no one is above the law mmm
got that America stop exercising your
rights the ones you thought were the law
and shut up because no one is above the
law except for Democratic voters
obviously they're not simply above the
law in fact they get to make their own
laws in fact they can make their own
countries if they want it's all totally
cool just as long as they vote in
November Jason Rance host a radio show
in Seattle he ventured into the nation
of Chazz earlier today and tonight he is
reporting from outside the Boy
of Chazz the DMZ that separates Seattle
from this emerging nation Jason thanks
so much for coming on what's it like
inch as well right now it's too violent
for us to go in it's a little bit too
scary for us to go in because when you
go in and you have a different opinion
than what they would like to be seen on
video they end up harassing you and they
assault you
I had a friend who's a reporter who got
assaulted just two nights ago when you
wait wait I'm sorry I have to I have to
stop you there I've got to check your
priveledge for a second aren't
developing nations all always seized by
turmoil isn't it a little racist to say
the Chazz is violent yes let me say that
they are peacefully challenged right now
they don't want us to talk about that in
fact when you hear from Mayor Jenny
Durkin I feel like I've never been more
embarrassed for the city before mayor
Jenny Durkin earlier today essentially
said that what we see is happening isn't
really happening
that despite the fact that they had to
board up all of the windows and the
doors to the east precinct before
removing all of their expensive
equipment and all of their evidence and
everything that they had there then put
a fence around it they said they weren't
actually abandoning the building
meanwhile there's not a cop in sight the
cops are told not to come here and that
of course is due to the violence that
we're told is in actual violence it's
peaceful protesters Jenny Durkin goes
after president Trump today because he
paid attention to this in a tweet last
night and earlier today and now it's
officially about Donald Trump lying
about domestic terrorists in this crowd
I can tell you because not only do I
live here but I cover an Tifa and I
cover anarchists there is a group in
this area in Chas that are anarchists
that are antifa
and there are in fact some community
organizers who have decided to
completely take over and we have ceded
this land to these individuals and the
implications of that cannot be
understated if folks think right now
that maybe they live in Los Angeles in
New York oh it's not gonna happen here
yeah it's gonna happen there we're
allowing it to happen here we're not
getting involved at all we're pretending
it doesn't exist I have to ask you Jason
since you're one of the very few I know
who's ventured inside this new nation
is it a tidy cheerful place have they
ironed out all the the kinks in the
sanitation etc what's it look like well
yeah so it's not necessarily tidy
however the City of Seattle has decided
to send in crews to do some cleanups and
add some toilets for them so we're
actually enabling this kind of behavior
so there are beginnings of foreign aid
obviously there is a lot of trash of
course I mean this is a developing
nation so we need we do need to give
some financial aids at the beginning of
this it's we want to nurture this right
we want to grow this and maybe next week
instead of six blocks it'll be twelve
blocks maybe after that it can develop
into all of Capitol Hill if we're gonna
seed this I mean let's go all in because
apparently it's not that big of a deal
meanwhile Mayor Jenny Durkin won't come
down here and she certainly won't come
down here without armed security and
SWAT teams around the block to come in
just in case something goes down
meanwhile we still have no idea what the
East precinct is actually going to come
back but we can tell you that now when
you call 91 1 for a crisis in progress
it takes three times the amount of time
it normally would for them to report
because they're so undermanned and down
a building
it's it's absolutely disgraceful mayor
Jenny gherkin should be forced to live
in Chas as long as it's there I'm
serious she should be
it's her city jason raize she keeps her
address secret because of threats oh she
doesn't the rest of us get to live with
jazz okay kind of I'm sorry to figure
out how this works all right thank you
for that update and I hope you'll you'll
join us again as this nation flourishes
and grows absolutely